every day is a busy day for the euromax
team for 10 years now they've been
producing a daily half hour of life and
culture in Europe
reading from the German capital hello
and welcome to the show Yura max is
lifestyle pure showing its viewers that
Europe is colorful and exciting and full
of surprises the first program went on
air on june the 30th 2003 your honor
posted by karen helms did hello and
welcome to the first edition of our new
magazine euromaxx hello welcome to the
show hello in a very warm welcome to a
staff studied show hi there and welcome
to our latest edition from day one
euromax was broadcast both in English
and German on the saga Hollande had said
the common saw yes an old Scarborough's
let us know in magazines and here she is
with me in the studio welcome to the
show Julie Delpy working in the early
years prominent guests joined us in the
studio joining me now is the man himself
welcome to Euro max bud spencer in March
2008 euromaxx saw some major changes the
studio got a makeover and the show was
first broadcast in widescreen format
but over the decade the editorial staff
have kept their knack for picking
unusual topics that viewers don't easily
forget whether it's the roller coaster
restaurant or the horse hooves shoes
euromax is innovative the show's early
edition sent its video journalists
traveling from the North Cape to
Gibraltar in a camper in many of our
series euromax reporters left into the
unknown making new experiences would we
traveled around Europe as well Bonjour
from Paris hasta luego and a do au
revoir in 2011 we went to Berlin Fashion
Week and get away have you chosen this
one I think this is a perfect dress for
you this is the fabulous dress I expect
you're wondering what on earth I'm doing
there was plenty going on in the Berlin
studio as well for those of you who've
never met her before allow me to
introduce my alter ego in plaster and as
for fun I thought I'd dress the part
since day one the show's being made up
of regular features
like you're a max clip mania which
highlights the funniest and most
creative web clips and there were
award-winning formats to what of them
the strange world of Max X all the truth
about Germany series which saw Mikael
vigor investigate the accuracy of some
widespread clichés but why are Germans
so mad about this kind of music partner
stations around the world rebroadcast
euromax and its best moments in chinese
for example we're gonna morning how are
you shocked hello Joe West and since
februari 2012 DW has also been producing
euromax in Spanish and Arabic
bienvenidos a no esta segunda división
de Oro max st denver nilayam to say i do
non-official attend Geneva and Yura max
isn't only on TV you can also find it
online of all of dw's magazines it has
the most followers on Facebook fans
exchange ideas with the show's editors
keep up with your MX news and watch
videos it's been 10 exciting years and
now the team is looking forward to 10
more